so with my last video on the Iron Man
armors doing so well a figure boot would
continue the trend by going over marks
11 through 20 so where most of the Iron
Man armors up to this point were
designed explicitly for Tony Stark we
take a brief reprieve and with the
market Levin we focus on the war machine
armor which first appeared in Iron Man
in number 281 and 1992 coming out of a
conflict with a group called the Masters
of Cylons who combine their love for
technology and the samurai principles of
Bushido during the three-part story
between issues 281 and 283 Tony Stark's
nemesis Justin Hammer had tricked the
Masters of silence into fighting Tony
during which time start developed an
assault armor which capitalized on the
mark 10 in terms of his ability to cope
with technology but also function in a
manner allowing for start to operate as
an army of one because a conclusion of
the three-part event culminated in a
former love interest named Cathy dare
shooting Stark with the world still
unaware that Stark was iron man James
Rhodes was appointed to the head of
Stark Industries and operated as iron
man using the war machine armor in terms
of its abilities because it was designed
to be a literal one-man wrecking machine
the war machine armor continues a trend
of repulsors from the hands and the
unibeam of the chest but also adds twin
chain guns a wrist mounted flamethrower
Gatling guns a box rocket launcher and a
pulse cannon for long range attacks as a
result the armor uses uranium 236 to
give it a polycarbonate coating allowing
for the same plating as tanks and
utilizes Teflon coated armor-piercing
rounds thermite grenades tear gas flares
and smoke grenades transitioning to the
mark 12 this armor was first introduced
in iron man issue number 290 and is the
most popular of the non manned armor
variants because the suit does not
contain a person and instead it uses a
series of neural commands from start
allowing for real-time control more
emphasis was put on expanding the
abilities of the existing armors
allowing the unibeam to function as a
searchlight tractor beam image inducer
ultraviolet light and EMP the repulsors
were also capable of higher outputs than
the normal armors by utilizing a series
of electronic pods stored within the
interior of the armor itself in addition
to this the armor contains pulse bolts
heat beams a disruption field
sonic disorder for
tronic frequencies a flamethrower
shoulder-mounted Gatling gun micro
rocket launcher particle beam taser
teargas fiber wire energy shields and
absorption grid which absorbs
energy-based attacks to power and
enhance the armor auto pilot should the
neural connection become severed
operating on the last command provided
and returning after its completion as
well as radar sonar infrared ultrasound
and the ability to determine whether a
being is alive or dead transitioning to
the mark thirteen this armor first
appeared in Iron Man is number 300
however unlike all of the other varying
forms of the Iron Man armor which use a
fully integrated system operating as a
single unit the mark 13 maintains its
signatures to design and its normal
complement of weapons but also utilizes
a series of independently functioning
add-ons with the most popular being the
Hulkbuster as a result the mark 13 is
usually just called the Hulkbuster armor
because it was designed specifically to
be a Swiss Army knife of sorts the mark
13 uses a full spectrum analyzer with an
adamantium tip probe allowing it to
penetrate virtually any surface and
analyze its makeup as well as weaknesses
a magnetic railgun with explosive shells
semifluid energy absorber polymer
designed to subdue foes by blanketing
them in the substance a gravimetric
field generator to cancel out the
electromagnetic field of the earth of
Holly bond adhesive compound a cryogenic
compound module to freeze beings or
objects and stasis a magnetic compound
module which manipulates the atomic
structures of objects forces in the bond
or push into a part a hybrid irmak
injector microsurgery equipment and
shoulder mounted weapons finally the
hope Buster add-on integrates magno
hydraulic pseudo musculature providing a
massive boost in strength and capable of
going toe-to-toe with the Hulk until
banner strength exceeds what the armor
is capable of withstanding in addition
to this the armor was coated with impact
resistant carbon composite plating
keeping it from being blown to pieces
the first time the hole punched it
moving on to the mark 14 this armor
first appeared in Iron Man 2 number 318
and 1995 however this model only
appeared eight times of Marvel Comics
and as far as I can tell was designed
explicitly to cope with the sub-zero
temperatures of the arctic weather
whenever stark visited his bunker in the
southern hemisphere of the United States
continuing this line of thought
regarding the mark 15
this armor actually made its debut at
the same time as the mark 14 as part of
the force work series which saw start
forming his own team when the Avengers
and Avengers West Coast rosters were
combined a villain named immortus had
disguised himself as Kane the Conqueror
and manipulated stark into developing a
legitimate base of operations for force
works in California but also developing
a hidden base in the Arctic that housed
a time travel device where the
completion of this story would see star
killed replaced by a younger version of
himself from another reality and
Franklin Richards setting everything
back to normal during the heroes return
event following the onslaught saga
during starch time under the influence
of immortus the mark 15 armor was
designed to look especially menacing
regarding his physical appearance while
only adding a couple of enhancements
from previous models in terms of its
abilities the mark 15 armor presents
oversized gauntlets on the forearms
which move the repulsors from the hands
to this large section providing more
power the gauntlets were also capable of
discharging fine focused lasers tractor
beams a heat beam acid as well as a mist
capable of encasing objects or beams and
ice this armor also contained gyro
stabilization in the boots allowing for
better balance in addition to magnetic
brakes and inertial dampeners which
replace on the armor two key projectiles
from ricocheting off the armor as well
as improved software for threat analysis
with the mark 16 armor this model
debuted an Iron Man vol 3 issue number
one in 1998 coming out of Franklin
Richards returning start along with the
Avengers and the Fantastic Four to the
main Marvel Universe during the heroes
return storyline stark underwent
designing a new suit of armor something
to note here is that this armor was
actually temporarily abandoned but it
was infiltrated and taken over by Ultron
now in terms of its capabilities the
repulsor controls were upgraded allowing
for variable settings rather than a
single pulse of energy while still
maintaining a uni-beam pulse bolts were
also continued but rarely used due to
the vast amount of energy they drained
as well as the introduction of a sonic
wave beam projector to take out multiple
enemies at once
imaging sensors like radar thermal
seismic sonar infrared telephoto and
fluoroscopic as well as a mobile
targeting array with advanced targeting
systems capable of detecting motion as
small as one hundredth of an inch a
special feature this armor also
contained which was not available on
other armors up until this time was the
ability for stark to provide a projector
allowing
both himself and one other person to
move in stealth mode now the March 17
armor actually debuted in Fantastic Four
volume 3 issue number 15 because the
story had seen Reed Richards developing
something known as a fold space transept
er which functioned by quite literally
folding space in on itself allowing for
instantaneous travel throughout the
universe the March 17 armour was
originally still in testing phase but
used to carry out Reed's process as a
result aside from being designed with
the standard load out of repulsors a
uni-beam and a responded weapon the
armour plating was durable enough to
withstand all feasible scenarios while
in space moving to the mark 18 Armour
this model appeared in the four part
series iron man bad blood with issue
number four and came out of Tony Stark's
selling his obsolete branch off evader
Armour to Justin Hammer all hammer pose
as an anonymous buyer because Justin
Hammer had previously instigated the
honor wars after stealing Starks
technology on the Iron Man armors stark
develop the mark 18 as a suit design and
confront hammer in his orbiting space
platform in terms of his capabilities
like the March 7 the mark 18 focus on
stealth but contained a multitude of
upgrades from the March 7 because it's
less durable than the mark 7 this was
offset by the ease of use and
controllability in terms of piloting the
armor was also covered in a compression
gel in addition to using solid fuel
Rockets that could be dismounted after
leaving the atmosphere allowing for a
stealthier approach furthermore instead
of boot Jets the suit used maneuvering
pods at the base of the feet knees and
hits to minimize energy output and
reduces energy signature the suit also
saw the introduction of a solar sail to
allow the armor to remain charged while
in space in addition to utilizing radar
jamming and stealth masks with the mark
19 this model debuted in Iron Man vol 3
issue number 42 but because the mark 16
had become sentient after it was taken
over by Ultron stark actually didn't
want to create another suit of armor for
fear that Ultron would reanimate through
it and use it as a means to launch an
attack however the decision was made to
create a new armor using skin technology
which stood for synth kinetic
interfacing nano fluid designed to be
both malleable but become as hard as
adamantium on command the artificial
intelligence Jocasta function as the
armors operating system which at the
time was actually a big gamble since
Jocasta had been developed by Ultron as
a wife but
against him in terms of disabilities in
addition to the use of skin technology
on the exterior the suit contained the
standard load out of repulsors impulse
bolts but also added a new technology
called the Omni beam which use absorb
energy and directed it outwards in
addition to this the mark-19 contained
an energy blade in the gauntlet which
could be used as wealth a sword and a
shield as well as a series of probes
that contain limited repulsors image
inducers a sensory array and can
function as smart bombs seeking out
targets and detonating a new feature of
this armor was that it actually had the
ability to blend in with its environment
similar to a chameleon in addition to
entering an emergency mode we would shut
down automatically find a safe location
and cloak itself until it could be
picked up finally the mark 20 debuted in
Iron Man vol 3 issue number 50 and where
it was originally designed to function
similar to past models following a
battle with two Mugen the son of
Mandarin Starks most dangerous enemy the
armor was designed in order to cope with
two Mugen superhuman ability and iron
fists like punching power to this end
repulsors were included we used the
variant referred to as crowd control
where multiple blasts are shot at once
in a fashion similar to scatter shot in
addition to an enhanced effect being
achieved with the unibeam every pulsers
firing in sequence the sonic weaponry
was also improved allowing for beings or
objects to be pushed away from Stark in
addition to adding a concussive effect
rendering foes unconscious for a time
furthermore because two Mugen had
inherited the ten reins of the Mandarin
the suit was also designed to focus
explicitly on repelling the various
abilities of these rings by using a
magnetic pulse furthermore the on-board
EMP was improved a basic force field was
implemented with an algorithm that
constantly changed its frequency to keep
it impenetrable liquid oxygen cells
allowed for both underwater and space
breathing with the exhaled carbon
dioxide used to enhance the suits
propulsion capabilities with that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end and let me know down in the
comments section whether or not you guys
want to hear about Marc's 21 through 30
and I will catch you guys later
peace